what mistakes to screenwriters make with
structure invariably
screenwriters are failing to tell a
story they're failing to realize that
structure is a way to maximize the
impact of their story and that they are
ending up presenting a situation instead
of telling a story so the my method is a
way for them to identify the eight
elements that are required to tell a
story to put them all on a one-page form
and to see how structure can work for
them not against them in order to help
them find the most surprising and
satisfying paths for their story so it's
almost as if new screen writers or
screenwriters that's haven't mastered
structure or almost like recounting it's
like it for a deposition and they're
sort of recounting though just the facts
instead of actually putting flavor and
flair and the characters voice I think
there's can be resistance to thinking
that structure is gonna somehow inhibit
them you know that it's going to keep
them from finding their voice when in
fact it's quite freeing all it is it's
you know it's it's you know when people
study improv improv comedy is not just
people who run around crazy on stage
right structure is a big part of it
understanding the structures behind
different improv scenarios allows the
performers to find these interesting
pads so it allows them to free
themselves so they need just a little
bit of structure in order to discover
those moments but without them you're
gonna end up floundering so what is the
voice of the character I mean I think
about when I listen to let's say
Margaret Atwood or Alice Monroe read one
of their stories there's a very distinct
you know you feel that that person is
real it seems like such an it's such a
very vague thing like the character
voice but it's so important how does
somebody kind of like bring it down and
make it tangible well when I talk about
voice I'm not talking about the
character's voice I'm talking more about
the writers voice that the writers voice
needs to come through and that comes
through in everything all of the
elements it comes it through and your
word choice in the way you choose to
describe action in you the choice of the
structure and the story and the
characters all of the elements work
together are going to contribute to you
discovering your voice and your voice is
what makes you unique as a writer what
makes it more than just plot that
there's something unique and ultimately
that's what screenwriters are selling of
themselves is that they have a really
unique voice that captures the
imagination of the reader and makes us
experience it like a movie and not feel
like we're reading a short story oh it's
the writers voice the writers going on
yeah Eric to poison on the protagonist
in Jack okay
so finding the writers voice okay that I
can see where can the writer have too
much of their own voice can it is it
good to vary their style and their voice
white or scantily get in their own way
in the beginning and that's why in the
beginning you know the real screen
writing 101 approach is tells you to
stick to what is seen and what is heard
right then and that's that's what we
teach beginners because we want to start
training readers to writers to rethink
from what you might have learned from
writing prose which could be very
internal where we're getting inside
characters heads you don't really do
that in screenwriting at least you know
what we're generally not gonna hear the
character's thoughts literally unless
use voiceover and voiceovers in advance
tool but as you become a more
experienced writer you're gonna be you
should experiment more with breaking
rules and with not worrying about
sticking to only what is seen and heard
and finding ways to discover your voice
as a writer so that when a reader reads
you
it doesn't violate the rules of
screenwriting it still is something that
we can imagine in a movie but it brings
the words to life in such a way that
engages the reader because what readers
are human ultimately we want to be
delighted we want to be charmed by your
writing so ultimately I think to
distinguish yourself you're gonna want
to explore your voice and it's become
more charming as a writer in the
beginning though you're gonna get in
your own way if you're doing that too
much until you've sort of trained your
brain to stop to think more naturally
about what is being seen and heard and
more naturally about seeing everything
as a movie but voice is something that
you definitely going to need to develop
along the way if you want to distinguish
yourself as a screenwriter what about
getting in your own way in terms of
copying someone else's voice
unintentionally so if I'm devouring all
these William Goldman scripts and I'm
just trying to really sink into them and
then I somehow end up writing in his
style emulating him not knowing I'm
doing that I don't know that that's a
bad thing in the beginning you know we
in any form of artistry write we are
going to copy those whose style we
admire in a way as a way to eventually
find our own voice you know if you're
literally lifting things that that would
be a problem if you are you know and
ultimately you're going to have to
develop your own voice it definitely is
I can tell you it will be irritating to
read readers and I'll tell you a
particular writer that this was a
problem with is a little a lot of young
writers copy Tarantino for example you
know in the late 90s so we're you know
because he had such a strong voice and
broke the rules in such a way that
everyone everyone wants to break the
rules and so and that certainly can
irritate a reader when they recognize
it's so clearly somebody else's voice
that it it definitely can have a back
effect where we'd rather not try it any
voice at all if you're gonna just cop it
where we feel you're just copying
someone else's voice but really great
writers who have very specific voices
and styles I think that can be a way to
start learning how to develop your voice
to try to I don't I don't want to say
copy but to emulate in some ways a
William Goldman style if you admire it
as a way to ultimately develop your own
voice you're gonna want to ultimately
develop your own voice because the world
probably doesn't need another William
Goldman voice out there alternately what
they want is your voice right so you it
should be a step along the way to find
that
you